is Europe ready to tackle Ebola on its
own territory that had helped enough the
countries most affected by the scourge
as the number of victims passes 4500
according to the world health
organization m eps are calling for a
more coordinated response from the
european commission and for more funding
to fight the virus silver-backed Ebola
if you add Kapoor Deepika virus elf
erotic a novice in on a freak iberia
sheridan on Guinea anaerobic admits ax
is eaten for a sportive a litter box 200
on occasion Deborah park open on the
cement cement in the oppidum wondrous
pod rapidly male person contaminate let
us consider his elusive problem dolly
media the e use 28 member states have
pledged 500 million euros for the fight
against the epidemic of which 180
million is coming from the European
Commission a European anti abola
coordinator is set to be appointed in
the next few days by member states many
workers in Europe's auto and steel
industries in France Spain and Belgium
have been hit hard by the economic
crisis as a result large numbers have
been laid off whenever a business lays
off more than 500 workers the country
affected can claim financial support
through the e use globalization
adjustment fund Hopi an adjuster
memorialization neck unification c42 le
travail ott license key 18 and Parvati
provide block permit system on SWA body
formation so parties allocation of vodka
please the hood who video home at home
lips ele te e do hood who ville anova
150 million euros had to be allocated
each year in the period 2014 to 2020
it's a pattern which we want to teach
and not the overall unemployment to
support financially it's not the
targeted target is learning and training
education and to give the government and
the people in the administration at
hands to get best practice in benchmark
in this area this week Emmy PS have
endorsed for requests for support for
4441 redundant workers a second life for
Euroskeptic leaders whose group Europe
of freedom and direct democracy folded
last week after defection left it short
of the member state minimum Robert yaris
wafi Vuckovich from poland's congress of
the new right has said he'll join nigel
farage from u cube and david Borelli
from the five star movement mr. Yosh
carriages party has made disparaging
remarks about women and supportive ones
about Hitler